what you're watching right now is the
world's first ever hydrogen fuel cell
semi truck on the road thanks to a
company called nikola motors the only
problem is this video is fake
nicholas simply towed the truck to the
top of the hill in a remote stretch of
road let the truck roll down the hill
and film the truck rolling down that
hill at an angle so it looked like it
was running on its own it's staged it
was a fraud designed to swindle
investors into dumping more money into
this tesla killer allegedly
nikola eventually had to come clean and
admit it didn't even have a working
motor but by the time mission of guilt
came out two years have passed and it
was only after a bombshell report came
out from a short seller research firm
called hiddenberg research not
affiliated with them by that time trevor
milton the founder of the company had
become a billionaire off of this
intricate web of lies allegedly this is
the story of how one man became a
billionaire by taking advantage of the
greed around the electric revolution how
he was able to pump his company to 20
billion dollars with zero working
products zero sales and zero revenue all
the while lying about quote nearly all
aspects of the business end quotes and
his eventual indictment by grand jury
for securities fraud
[Music]
right now nikola motors has over 19
million dollars in debt a staggering
amount we don't know what the interest
rate on that debt is but what we do know
is that getting trapped in that vicious
cycle where all your money is going
towards paying off high interest debt
every month to where you don't have any
money left over to save is a sure-fire
way of staying poor and if you're
drowning in a lot of high-interest debt
like the average american wouldn't it be
nice if you could take out a loan at a
much lower interest rate use that loan
to pay off your high interest debt so
you're left with only one single loan
that requires only one fixed monthly
payment with a clear payoff date so you
can escape this vicious cycle once and
for all well you're in luck because
that's where upstart comes in today's
video sponsor upstart is a fast easy way
to get a personal loan online to help
you pay off your high interest debt
whether you need to pay off your credit
cards consolidate a bunch of high
interest debt or you just need help
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you by giving you a loan that
requires only one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date instead of just
looking at your credit score upstart
takes in other factors like your income
current employment and credit history to
help you get a smarter rate for your
loan upstart offers loans of 1 000 to 50
000 and you can check your rate in
minutes without impacting your credit
score once approved you can receive your
funds in as little as one business day
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com jaytran that's upstart.com
jaketran use my url in the description
below to let them know i sent you
upstart.com jake trim
[Music]
2020 was the year of the ev everyone was
watching tesla stock skyrocket to the
point where tesla was valid at over 400
billion dollars that's more than gm4
daimler and fiat combined so obviously
these regular car companies were under
huge pressure from analysts and
shareholders to electrify so their stock
could see similar gains they were being
left in the dust and had to catch up and
a great fast easy way to make your
company look more modern more up to date
more environmentally conscious is by
partnering up with an existing electric
car company so you don't have to do the
research and development yourself and
that's exactly what gm did except they
chose probably the worst option they
could in september 2020 they entered
into a strategic manufacturing
partnership with nikola motors this not
only made nicholas seem legit but it
sent both companies share skyrocketing
but as gm would soon find out nicolette
motors was far from the saving grace
they hoped for
[Music]
trevor milton the man behind nicole and
motors has had a sketchy track record to
say the least sure tech founders are
often criticized for being too ambitious
or too optimistic but according to
hindenburg research trevor took this way
too literally and nicola modis was far
from his first time doing this after
trevor sold his first business a
security and alarm business trevor
started a used car sales website that
ultimately failed but it got him into
the world of evs so in 2009 he partnered
with an engineer named mike shrout to
form d-hybrid a company that would
manufacture cars fueled by shroud's
compressed natural gas conversion
technology after d hybrid's launch
trevor got the ceo of swift
transportation a giant semi-truck
shipping company to start marketing
their tech using a converted pickup
truck as a demo the ceo of swift was so
impressed that he signed a development
agreement and paid 2 million for a 9
stake in d hybrid a return d hybrid
would convert 10 trucks for testing and
once successful another 800 trucks for
sale surprise surprise a little later
swift allegedly sued trevor and d hybrid
stating the company only delivered five
trucks and none of them worked
unsurprisingly swift also claimed the
company officers had used their
investment money for personal benefits
but even though that was a disaster
trevor still came out on top with his
initial cash running out he reached out
to new investors claiming his contract
with swift was worth more than 250
million dollars and tried to get a
buyout deal with a company called
sustainable power group llc but instead
of waiting to see what would happen with
d hybrid trevor abandoned ship and
decided to start a new but not very
different company with his dad called d
hybrid systems llc he kept the name kept
the tech but left his partners in the
original company with nothing two years
after starting the hybrid systems he
sold it to wordington industries for
15.9 million dollars giving them almost
80 of the company but then it comes out
in a recorded conversation with a former
employee that the hybrid had to
allegedly conceal potentially fatal
product flaws to get the deal through
i freaking
helped design and develop and and fix
all these repairs that
worthington didn't know about but i was
in the field making the repairs so that
they wouldn't find out about it
these back of cab units were actually
falling off of the trash truck falling
off the trash like breaking off they
were shearing the damn freaking frames
and then coming off like nearly freaking
causing deaths
i was the guy in the field thinking
making sure that they didn't find out if
they had found out that would have
ruined the deal
with all this new money and all the
credibility he built up as a founder of
not one but two alternative energy
vehicle companies he set his sights a
little higher this time he used the fact
that he sold to warrington a well-known
and respected company and moved on to
the next big thing turning a basically
unknown company called blue jean tech
into a 20 billion dollar house of cards
that we now know as nicola motors
nicola motor started a lot like how all
his other business ideas ended with a
lot of stretching of the truth
in 2016 nicole and motor started to duct
tape together third-party truck parts in
an effort to build their first truck
these parts were sourced through
partnership agreements which were again
based on exaggerations about how great
or groundbreaking his tech really was
and on may 9 2016 nikola motors comes
out of stealth mode announcing it would
transform the u.s transportation
industry with their electric semi truck
dubbed the nikola one the company behind
this revolutionary startup the head of
infrastructure turned out to be the
former ceo and manager of an idaho golf
club
the chief engineer had a background in
mostly software development and
repairing pinball machines
and of course there was trevor's brother
who was put in charge of the hydrogen
fuel cell development even though he was
a concrete pourer in maui and has no
experience in this field
oddly enough sometime during the early
days of nikola motors trevor had laid
the groundwork to ensure that if he ever
got fired he would one get all his
company shares at once to be able to
cash out and two be paid 20 million over
the next two years after he was fired if
trevor was captain of a ship this move
seems to indicate that he was definitely
not planning on following the tradition
of the captain being the last to abandon
ship and this was used before the ship
even started to sink much or less
deliver on a working product
on december 1st 2016 trevor unveiled the
nikola 1 what he called a fully
functioning alternatively powered truck
but not just any truck this truck was by
far the most state of the art truck ever
built in history this thing fully
functions and works this is a real truck
this is not a pusher and keep in mind
this was just 7 months after they went
out of stealth mode what had taken most
ev developers years or decades to
perfect had taken trevor and his team
just a little over half a year
everything kind of starts when you're
young and you have a lot of paths in
life you can take but this was my path
to transform how trucking works
everything about it from the ground up
america was built on the backs of
diesels it's really incredible i love
the history of diesels it was developed
primarily because it was more efficient
and stronger than the alternatives at
the time
and now we face the same problems how do
we build something that's stronger more
efficient and cleaner and that's our
obligation it's our future how do we
take the past and improve on it and
that's what the nikola one does
you'll see it up on the screens are
fully functioning screens
really incredible
we will have a
a chain on the on the seats
to prevent people from coming in just
for the safety i don't want someone to
end up doing something and driving this
truck off the stage
so we're going to try to keep people
from driving off but this thing fully
functions and works which is really
incredible
and just to make sure there was no doubt
in anyone's mind how well this truck was
functioning and how groundbreaking it
was trevor repeated three times that the
truck was real and it was a hundred
percent working for every doubter out
there that said that there's no way this
is true
abs how can that be possible we've done
it it's my pleasure to actually let you
guys enjoy the night see the truck know
it's real touch it feel how sturdy it is
you're gonna see that this is a real
truck this is not a pusher
thank you so much everyone i appreciate
it thank you
[Applause]
investors and viewers went nuts over it
and it seemed like nicola could only go
up but in reality the truck was not real
and in fact a pusher a few years later
in june 2020 bloomberg put out an
article that claimed the truck they
unveiled had not been working and had a
couple parts missing at the launch event
there was even an electric cable running
under the stage to power the screens
inside the truck in response trevor
blasted the whole article and claimed
everyone there knew the truck wasn't
working at the launch despite him
emphasizing that i did more than three
times
so we're gonna try to keep people from
driving off but this thing fully
functions and works which is really
incredible it's my pleasure to actually
let you guys enjoy the night see the
truck know it's real touch it feel how
sturdy it is you're gonna see that this
is a real truck this is not a pusher the
bloomberg article turned out to be right
just three months before the launch the
truck was nothing more than the frame
and some wheels the factory wasn't in
production yet workers were getting
parts at the hardware store last minute
to scrap the truck together and the
truck has zero hydrogen capabilities
even though it was supposed to be
running on a hydrogen fuel cell
right before the launch emails were even
sent between employees trying to make
the truck look as functional as possible
before revealing it to the public so all
the unbelievable progress nicola motors
had made was exactly that unbelievable
but with all the exaggerations involved
in making nicolette look legit you'd
think at least one employee would speak
up and become a whistleblower but that's
where the intimidation tactics come in
[Music]
having employees sign ndas is nothing
new or suspicious however issuing legal
warnings to former employees to prevent
them from discussing the company having
tesla fans who visit nicholas signed an
nda and having the actors in their
infamous video of the truck rolling down
the hillside ndas is a little bit more
suspect and that one video would
eventually lead to their downfall but in
the meantime it got the job done and
generated a lot of hype
[Music]
to make this video possible the company
scouted a remote location in the middle
of utah this particular stretch of road
was two miles long was perfectly
straight with a perfect three percent
grade great is how sloppy a road is just
enough length and slope to get a semi
truck without a motor to roll and the
camera was positioned to make the road
look fairly level and even uphill and
investigators even tested the exact same
site themselves rolling an suv from park
to neutral down the same hill they
reached 56 miles per hour over 2.1 miles
the media took the bait and the hyphen
nickel and motors exploded but right
after this video launched the nikola 1
development was abandoned the motorless
semi truck served its purpose create
hype make it look credible enough to
drive in the right partners and get more
investors to fork up their cash to get
in on this revolutionary startup before
it's too late and just two years later
trevor milton becomes a billionaire
the dream of any startup is to have a
liquidity event basically a fancy term
that allows the owners of a startup to
cash out see when building or investing
in a private startup you can't sell your
shares of a company on the stock market
because it's a private startup it's not
listed on the stock market yet so for
the most part even if the company is
worth a billion dollars all your shares
are worthless if you can't sell them
easily that's why the goal of every
startup is to either get acquired by a
bigger company that will hopefully give
you cash for your shares or the best
option is to go public on the stock
market which usually gets you a lot more
money that way you can sell your shares
in the stock market and the public pays
cash for your shares so writing the wave
of the 2018 demo video which had not
been exposed yet nicola motor school's
public via is back on june 2020. in a
nutshell a spack is basically a way for
a company to go public without all the
financial scrutiny that comes with the
traditional method of going public an
ipo spax were all the rage on wall
street until the recent collapse because
it allowed for companies like nicola who
didn't have a working product or revenue
in other words they weren't real
companies to dump their worthless shares
on the public to extract money out of
them all the while avoiding all the
scrutiny that would expose their bad
financials if they would have went with
an ipo which was the mistake wework made
so with a spec you get the best of both
worlds so nikola goes public the stock
price skyrockets and trevor becomes an
overnight billionaire all thanks to his
electric vehicle company that doesn't
have any electric vehicles
people even started comparing him to
elon musk it seemed like nothing could
go wrong but the house of cards would
soon start unraveling
[Music]
going public opens you up to a lot of
criticism from analysts journalists
short sellers basically anyone that can
profit from your demise now that you're
public and trevor and nicola got a lot
of this trevor's response threatened
journalists with lawsuits
but the final nail in the coffin came on
september 10 2020. around three months
after they went public hindenburg
research publishes their extensive
report detailing all the information and
much more that you're learning about in
this video it goes viral in mainstream
international media getting featured on
the wall street journal financial times
cnn barrens and cnbc and just 10 days
later trevor resigns from nikola motors
but thanks to the groundwork he laid
that we talked about earlier he walked
away with more than 90 million dollars
in stocks and payouts over the next two
years nine months after that trevor
milton is charged with two counts of
security fraud and wire fraud
he is currently awaiting trial at the
time of recording this video
[Music]
a few things to keep in mind number one
i personally don't like making videos
targeting individuals in a bad light
especially when they're small fish i
think those videos are just sad and kind
of pathetic but in this case nicola was
vowed at over 20 billion dollars at
their peak and man the evidence is
undeniably stacked against them number
two this video was primarily based on a
report released by hindenburg research a
short sale of firm that has a financial
incentive to paint nicolette motors in
the most damning light possible and
judging by nikola's current stock price
they made a lot of money from it are
they biased of course but man it does
not look good for nicola number three
trevor milton was indicted but he's
still innocent until proven guilty but
again it's not looking good for him even
if you left out everything else we
talked about in this video and just
focused on the fake semi truck video
that they ended up admitting wasn't
functional it still doesn't look good
for him and number four nicola motors is
still running today under a new ceo and
revised vision i would definitely
proceed with caution but who knows maybe
they'll be better this time they still
have three electric semi trucks listed
on their website to go on sale within
the next few years but time will tell
update and the myriad of other electric
vehicle starters will ever go to markets
[Music]
if you're new here and you're not
subscribed already we make video essays
just like this one every single week on
the most provocative thought-provoking
stuff in the world of business money
power crime war all the above we have a
good time here click subscribe you can
always dislike and unsubscribe whenever
you want so you have nothing to lose
anyways that's gonna wrap up this video
thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome i've been jake stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you